I just came across a study that showed taking a probiotic with or post antibiotic actually
slowed recovery of healthy microbiota.
I thought I said it to you and then another person said is absolute lymphocyte, monocyte,
neutrophil, eosinophil, and basophil in blood tests, better to be closer to the lower range
or higher range.
If it is closer to the lower range, does this mean there is activity in the body to raise
it or does it mean the immune system is weak?
So it depends on which one we're talking about.
So your absolute, this is called your differential on your CBC.
So when you do a CBC, you are looking at the total weight blood cell count, total red blood
cell count, and the factors of red blood cell and differentiating anemia, and then the
differential of the white blood cell count is breaking out lymphocytes so that you understand
that you could do a further study of lymphocytes that have a lymphocytes panel and break that
down into T cells, T hemp ourselves, B cells, etc., natural killer cells and such.
But the differential is going to show percentage of lymphocyte, monocyte, neutrophil, eosinophil,
basophil, and then an absolute value of those things.
So is it better to be closer to the low end or closer to the high end?
Well, it isn't better to be either, it's better to be in the middle.
So what you're really looking for, if your white blood cell count is within normal limits,
then typically there's not much to look at when there's not as big a reason to look at
the differential.
So it's when the white blood cell count, the total weight blood cell count is abnormal, then
we want to look at the differential.
So if my white blood cell count is 5.0, which is like perfect, then there's really not a
need to look at the differential.
The only reason I would is if I had some immune symptoms, let's say I had really
bad allergies, that I might still look at the differential and I might see eosinophils
being really high.
Now what does that tell you?
Does it tell you that you can manipulate that?
No, but it is a sign that you have really bad allergies.
So if you have really bad allergies, you might have elevation of eosinophils.
It doesn't mean that you can manipulate that somehow with a supplement or a drug to
lower the eosinophils and then my allergies are going to go away.
So I have elevated eosinophils because I have allergies.
Just like, okay, let's say my total weight blood cell count is low because I have a suppressed
immune system, could be because I have cancer, could be because I have a chronic infection
for years.
There's lots of reasons why I had low white blood cell count.
But then let's say my lymphocytes are low and my due to, let's say all of them are low.
Well, it doesn't mean I can manipulate that.
No, you want to find out why it's low.
So you would do some investigation to find out why it's low.
Do I have a chronic infection or if I already know I have a diagnosis of cancer, that could
be my why.
But let's say I recovered from cancer, I'm doing so much better, I feel great.
Why do I still have only a 3.5 white blood cell count?
Well, then you could do some more investigation to why it is.
Do I have a chronic infection that may be precipitated by cancer?
I don't know.
We could do some investigation.
Or if your total white blood cell count is high, let's say it's 8.0, which is still with
the normal range, but it's higher than it should be.
Then we could look at the differential and say my lymphocyte count is high also compared
to my neutrophilus.
So it could be I have an acute viral infection.
So if my white blood cell count is elevated, and I know I don't have a white blood cell cancer
like a leukemia or something, then if my white blood cell count is elevated, that's typically
an acute infection, and then you would differentiate whether it's elevated neutrophils, quite possibly
a bacterial infection, or elevated lymphocytes, quite possibly a viral infection.
So if I have this really slightly elevated total white blood cell count, let's say it's
7, and then eocentophils are really high.
It could be because of environmental allergies that I'm exposed to.
So that's how you look at that.
It's not better to have them to the lower range or better to have them to the higher range.
It doesn't make a difference if they're at the lower range or the higher range, but you're
looking at the total white blood cell count.
So and then you're using the differential to differentiate what could possibly be going